c'est Golen merci c'est regardez-moi
cette beauté regardez-moi cette grâce
elle était grâce de venir vous voir fait
une nouvelle coiure ah oui un petit peu
ouais j'ai vu c'est
quoi c'est pas mal parce que c'est plus
en arrière mais ça revient en avant
c'est un avant arrière j'adore voilà
voilà mais c'est Golen vous êtes
magnifique et je le dis toutes les
semaines franchement on a de la chance
de vous avir l'important c'est ce que je
vais dire non non de sont importants je
vous dire parce que c'est un plaisir de
vous écouter et d'apprendre mais c'est
ça rajoute c'est la cerise sur le gâteau
je vous le dis c'esten a eu un
remanimement il a un remanimement
d'ailleurs vous en avez parlé et cetera
il y a plein de gens qui m'ont dit mais
c'est quoi c'est quoi un remanimement
rien que ce mot si vous voulez
remanimement donc juste comme on fait à
chaque fois que j'ai le plaisir de venir
vous voir puisque je vous ai distribué
la Constitution c'est d'essayer
d'expliquer en mode simple ce qui est en
train de se passer sur le fonctionnement
des institutions donc remaniement c'est
un mot qui n'est pas dans dans le droit
c'est un mot tout simple ça veut dire
tout simplement réorganiser on
réorganise je sais pas une décoration on
réorganise un quartier on réorganise un
scénario réorganise une chanson donc
c'est un mot c'est un mot un nom commun
qui n'est pas spécifique à un remanement
gouvernemental le vrai mot en fait
puisque le Premier ministre change en
fait c'est qu'il y a un changement de
gouvernement donc dans le langage
courant toute la presse parle de
remanimement mais non le le mot précis
c'est qu'il y a un changement de
gouvernement changement c'est maintenant
parce que parce que le premier ministre
change donc c'est un nouveau
gouvernement quand il remanement général
c'est le premier ministre reste et on
change un petit peu les ministres et
cetera alors vous avez vu que ça dure
depuis quandême plusieurs jours ça
dévore toute l'actualité d'ailleurs la
majorité des Français doivent se dire
attendez nous on a le problème du coût
de l'énergie on sait pas si on va payer
le chauffage l'alimentation et et depuis
des jours et des
jours la presse ne parle que de ça mais
pourquoi la presse ne parle que de ça
parce que même les autres pays européens
sont très étonnés parce parce qu'il y a
qu'en France ah ou que ça existe non
pourquoi il y a qu'en France que ça
existe c'est parce que on a une
constitution une organisation un peu
particulière en France on est les seuls
comme cela c'est quoi la spécificité de
la France de la France par rapport au
pouvoir exécutifavoir un régime
présidentiel c'est ça il y a un
président de la République est élu au
suffrage universel donc il y a une
légitimité démocratique forte ailleurs
il est pas élu au surage universel celui
qui a vraiment le pouvoir dans les
autres pays c'est le premier min ah
ouais qui est le résultat de du vote au
Parlement donc c'est c'est beaucoup plus
rapide parce que il y a un vote au
Parlement c'est le parti qui a gagné les
élections dont le chef de parti qui
devient premier ministre ou alors parce
qu'il y a une coalition c'est le chef de
la coalition politique qui devient tout
de suite Premier ministre il y a pas ce
ce ce double voyez cette cette cette
lenteur et ce et et la gestion
finalement de ce qu'on appelle un
exécutif bicéphale c'est d'illeurs où il
y a deux deux autorités
donc dans la Constitution que je vous ai
distribué là je sais pas si on peut
projeter les petits documents que j'ai
vous ai fait euh le pouvoir du Président
de la République alors que fait un
président de la République par rapport
au pouvoir du Premier ministre c'est
pour ça que souvent qu'il y a des
tensions qu' un moment il y a des
tensions et donc à un moment le
président de la République se dit ben je
change de Premier ministre parce qu'il
est plus totalement aligné sur moi donc
c'est l'article 5 le président de la
républque il donne le cap voilà il est
arbitre le président le Président il est
arbitre dit la Constitution il s'occupe
du bon fonctionnement des pouvoirs
publics il assure il symbolise l'unité
de la nation et le Premier ministre
détermine et conduit le Gouvernement
détermine et conduit la politique de la
nation il dirige l'action du
gouvernement et surtout il est
responsable devant le Parlement ah oua
quelle est la différence entre un
président de la République et un premier
ministre le Premier ministre va au
Parlement vous avez vu il répond aux
questions il présente les lois et il
peut être destitué par un vote de C oh
là le président de la République vous
avez vu ne va pas au Parlement jamais de
la vie donc à un moment il y a une
tension parce que le premier ministre
prend une dimension politique parce que
c'est lui qui va au combat politique
combat et et donc c'est pour ça que dans
dans cette dans ce ce caractère du
double
exécutif souvent les autres pays sont
très étonnés et c'est pour ça aussi
qu'il y a des cohabitations qui n'existe
dans un aucun autre pays puisque quand
un président de la République est au
pouvoir mais qui perd les élections ben
c'est un ministre d'une autre
sensibilité politique qui arrive par ex
à l'époque il y avait Chirac et Jospin
voilà Chirac et Jospin il y a eu mitéran
et Chirac mitteran et Baladur et Chirac
et Jospin moi j'ai connu trois
cohabitations bah si la première j'étais
conseillère à l'Élysée fort mitéran et
Chirac la seconde j'étais député et la
troisème ben j'étais ministre de Jospin
quand il y avait Chirac donc j'ai connu
trois cohabitation et j'ai vu euh
effectivement les l'évolution
de de l'exercice du pouvoir vient quoi
Lionel je sa pas je il est pas Conseil
constitutionnel non non il j'aimais bien
il y avait une bonne tête voilà un peu
comment dans ma classe dans ma classe le
fils de dans ma classe s'en fout je
frense je
dis je te dis c'est voilà en pourquoi
c'est un peu compliqué parce qu'ensuite
il y a un équilibre politique tous les
partis politiques veulent être présentés
et cetera donc voilà comment les choses
les choses se passent il y a eu des
nouveautés il y a eu des nouveautés
alors quelles sont les nouveautés alors
Prisc donc très sympa porte-parole du
gouvernement à la place d'Olivier Verron
il a catine vain ministre du Travail à
la place d'Olivier du minist du travail
il s très souvent c'est tuas déjà fait
minist du travail déjà fait a Rachid
ministre de la Culture je suis content
moi aussi content pour
elleussiim bien
connais non je la connaissais pas moi
non
plus je PESS elle a bien feu non non non
c'est pas ouf non non je connais les
cont mais bien au moins au moins une
femme qui se laisse pas marcher sur les
PI exactement voilà une femme qui se
laisse pas marcher sur les
caster la mini des sports et ben elle
fait faire les deux maintenant ouiura
sûement des ministres délégués alors
voilà aussi qui intéressant qu'est-ce
que c'est une structure du gouvernement
il y a des ministres j'étais minist
délégué moi c'est assez drôle d'ailleurs
je raconé jeis vous raconter comment
j'étais nommé ministre on allez les
anecdotes alors anecdotes raconte-nous
la première fois que je suis nommé
ministre euh c'est c'est grâce si j'ose
dire à la démission d' d'un ministre qui
s'appelait bris Lalonde non je connais
était écologia bris Lalonde démissionne
et à ce je reçois un appel du président
de la République de l'époque François
mitteran qui me dit Briss langue
démissionne de toute façon au Parti
socialiste personne n'y connaît rien sur
la nature et cetera sur l'écologie SAU
vous fort alors parce que je étaé battu
pour main j'étais député des Deux Sèvres
j'avais fait les manifestations pour
maintenir le Maré pois de vin pour
m'opposer à l'enfouissement des déchets
nucléaires et cetera et François
miterran il y a que vous au PS qui
comprenez quelque chose à l'écologie et
c'est comme ça que je viens min de
l'écologie et c'est comme ça que en 92
comme je vous l'ai déjà raconté
j'assiste au premier sommet de de la
terre avec François mit autre anecdote
donc Jospin Premier
ministre je suis ministre délégué de
Claude al classe de ministre de
l'Éducation claudeallègre claudeallègre
donc au bout de quelques temps c'est le
bazar dans l'éducation nationale donc
Claude Aleg on dit Claude est débarqué
et cetera et à moi on me dit bon Claude
est débarqué mais comme tu es ministre
délégué il va être vexé si toi tu restes
au gouvernement donc tu es débarqué
aussi ou donc je je remballe mes
affaires c'est la vie je dis bon c'est
la vie on va passer à autre chose et
cetera donc je coupe mon téléphone je je
parle avec des amis et tout on disc non
non non enfin je passe ma soirée
tranquille quoi et quand je rallume mon
téléphone je vois 10 appels même plus de
matigon rappelé d'urgence rappelé
d'urgence B je rappelle et là forme de
désinvoleture aussi bon
du c'était Jospin encore un chosepinis
chercher des femmes donc allô qu'on
narrivait pas à te joindre et cetera oua
pu ben voilà j'ai oublié de de nommer le
ministre de la Famille non donc toi avec
tes quatre enfants tu feras laaff ah
c'est énorme c'est énorme j'avais quand
même été j'étais quand même député
j'avais été ministre François mitteran
et cetera bon tu prend ça dans le tu dis
rien tu dis bon faut prendre de toute
façon fort et puis donc de la famille
donc je t'ai mise de la famille si si
j'ai fait le congé de paternité j'ai
fait la garde alternée moi dès que j'ai
une responsabilité quelle qu'elle soit
ça avance et après avant de raccrocher
il me dit ah au fait quoi j'ai oublié
aussi les handicapés non tu seras
ministre de la Famille et des
handicapés
la désinvolture
désinvoltureolture et vous avez été
trois fois ministre voilà après c'était
avecuel Macron non et après c'était non
non non avec non non après
c'était le dernier bah c'était qui était
min après j'étais ministre de l'environ
de l'écologie sous sous Vals ah oui
c'est j'aime bien lui sympa voilà et les
dernier la dernière anecdote donc
c'est c'est à la fin donc du justement
de ce
quinquena Laurent Fab just par au
Conseil constitutionnel et moi je on me
demande que tu être ministre des
Affaires étrangères bien sûr ministre
des Affaires étrangères en plus j'avais
fait la COP et cetera donc c'est acté je
donne mon accord puis après on me
rappelle ah non donc j'ai raconté ça non
le cercle des hommes blancs là de plus
de 50 ans ah non pas elle toute la bande
sapin le
for Fabius qui était parti qui non pas
elle ouais ils se sont coal c'est quand
ils sont entre eux ils se battent entre
euou
et quand j'ai vu d'ailleurs cette
coalition contre contre Gabriel j'ai
revécu ça je me dis mais tout ce qui est
un peu innovant qui va lui refaire de de
le une autre anecdote alors vas-y vas-y
tu peux m'asseoir ou
pas c'est un ministre qui est nommé
parce qu'il a le même prénom et le même
nom que qui qu'un autre ministre et qui
est nommé à sa place Jean Michel
Boucheron dans les années 80 Michel
Boucheron oui qui était mare d'angoulem
et c'est pas lui qui devait être nommé
che
qui était député de re pas vrai et la
secrétaire se trompe
elle appelle l'autre Jean-Michel
Boucheron qui est nommé et ensuite ça se
passe mal parce qu'il reste min très peu
de temps et l'autre il a jamais été il a
jamais été
récupéréel c'est comme histoire c'est
ouf il a jamais il a jamais récupéré
j'adore les histoires de et pour
terminer Derrien dernière petite
derrière les barreaux d'une femme qui
avait le sens de l'humour on lui dit
mais qui était elle était secrétaire
d'État de de Marseille enfin j'ai pas
donné son nom parce que ouais le truc
mais alors donc on lui dit elle sensum
parce qu'on lui dit elle dit euh le jour
où j'étais plus ministre il y a des
ministres qui qui ça leur monte à la
tête pu le jour où ils sont plus dans la
vie faut savoir assumer he il faut être
résilient faut assumer les hauts les bas
et cetera et on lui dit mais comment
est-ce que vous êtes rendu compte que
vous n'étiez plus ministre alors elle
fait c'est parce que je suis monté à
l'arrière d'une voiture et elle a pas
démarré oh là
là bravo je
l'adore je l'adore je l'adore je l'adore
je l'adore je
l'adore je l'adore je l'adore c'est ma
SEO à moi j'adore cétait Champé les
années très très lo j'adore avec class
j'adore elle a la classe franchement se
elle aurait ê au gouvernement c'est où
ouais